[Music]
in crazx news submitted by can you live
without your dick
I think Malays would be fine yeah I've
lived about like 20 health away 28 I
went about to be 21 28 oh [ __ ] oh you
about to be 29 okay thank you I'm about
to be 28 - yeah me three but I lived all
my life in that one oh I always had one
what the [ __ ] does that mean I have your
dick oh I see yeah but you said you had
a dick I was a good do you ever dreamt
that you had a dick though I've had
those and those were week was it fun
okay the first time when I was trying to
learn how to masturbate it was I could
didn't know about the clitoris or
anything and I used to pretend like in
my head the fantasy was that a girl was
sucking my dick because that was easier
for me to understand the feeling of then
like cuz there was nothing there I felt
like I mean question yeah I had an
interesting conversation with a friend
of mine who is of the lesbian nature she
says that all girls can squirt is that
true
that's what I said she goes no she goes
all girls can I'm like is there
something that lesbian women know I bet
there is like a gland or something I
don't know science about Anatomy right
enough to know and say a fact but I can
tell you that I have before but I don't
know how that happened it just happened
I never have you probably have you just
don't know right now that woman's
squirting is a myth 100 percent feel bit
yes he has the K chance I thought it was
at first and I was so embarrassed
yeah I was so embarrassed because I
thought I was involuntarily peeing is
that what feels like you feel like you
know don't feel it comes out of a
different place like yeah I just I just
didn't understand what was happening cuz
I didn't even know about that I've never
seen a woman squirt and therefore they
did not she told me she told me
otherwise I feel like there's a bunch of
different like doctors saying one way
and doctors saying another way so I
the medical community has determined
there's no actual proof to it yeah okay
well okay chance that's my understanding
it's got to be like a certain part that
you touch that makes it happen like a
sea anenome yeah there's something I
can't scare it away but it'll happen you
ever used to poke those no they would
grow on rocks on the beach and you poco
and they like squirt oh are those sea
squirts or see them I think they're seen
enemies I don't know I was out of the
costume so I fix the other day a man
traveled a thousand miles to cut off the
penis of the new man dating his
ex-girlfriend awesome but he had to
touch it so he gay
that's Geico right there dude that's
high school guy logic yeah cuz it yeah
but you did touch it so therefore
heretofore you are gay saying that you
touched it yes this man is from Florida
of course Oh dick chopping dudes a lot
of bath salts halfs that with Bob it's
from Bobby from Lorena Bobbitt fame yeah
she threw it in the forest didn't she
john bobbitt got his dick cut off by
lorry on about the window yeah and then
they found out he got it back on and he
made a porno oh you need a portal fight
he got a replacement one oh the same one
yeah I thought he did porn it's like
telephone yeah everyone's got a
different job at story I love it you've
never did porn and I did no no that was
after after yeah after after he got his
dick attached yeah crazy that was in
Virginia by the way I just googled it
happened in Virginia hometown that was a
good close to home story for us oh okay
yeah oh what the [ __ ]
so anyway back to this story urban
legend so Justin he's 28 years old
beautiful real so currently what he did
is he went to Atlanta wonderful and then
he flew over to nobody to Ohio man so he
didn't even get a direct flight he had
to buy it one stop so the whole time
he's plotting and [ __ ] he's just he's
just chilling at the airport like I'm
gonna cut this [ __ ] dick off so this
dude flew over right and then he waited
for this 26 year old man who is now
dating
Justin's ex and he was waiting outside
this guy's house and finally he came the
victim came outside around 1:00 a.m.
that's him Justin approached him beat
him over the head with the tire iron and
knocked the man unconscious he carved
his initials into his leg
and then cut his penis off and he just
left it he dragged him over to a nearby
fence and oh no - behind a car and then
he just left him there to bleed out and
around 3:15 a.m. that's when a passerby
found him but where did it go oh he kept
it as a souvenir he tossed it over a
fence I hope there wasn't a dog there
this person is a [ __ ] animal dude
yeah this person charged away but not
only that like the victim what happened
to him so over the next several months
he was treated for traumatic brain
injuries fractures and lacerations and
now he suffers from severe brain damage
and he requires around-the-clock care oh
my god just for dating some girl I know
it's completely innocent from what we're
this is insane that's all I know and
this is the attacker why does he look
like a 1940's like straight-up black
dude from like long long time ago
it looks like Geek Squad that - I don't
think he looks like his girlfriend aging
that's what looks like she could be
girlfriend or something that's weird
after you tell he just looks like what
those black tooth is just only these
asian girls he's like the black dudes
that like to watch Naruto and then
they're kind of weeb a little bit and
then they like to date Asian girls I
don't know and they love going to
comic-con is that just Josh are you just
describing Josh on top of your head
right now
maybe so use the samurai sword that's
crazy you know and then he like attacked
the victim he just went back to the
airport he bought his one-way ticket
back to Atlanta like nothing happened
like nothing after he spent like a
thousand dollars I know I thought I was
just gonna get away with it really we
carved his initials in there so what the
[ __ ] yeah what the [ __ ] all I have to
say is love makes people do crazy things
know
but he's worth that so what does the
girl thing does the girl commented
nothing what was she saying yeah this is
pretty crazy something like I never miss
anything
it's got to feel weird that you dated
that guy that did that crazy I think
yeah now she has to stay with a [ __ ]
man or else she's gonna be a [ __ ] oh
yeah it's like you're just with them for
his [ __ ] dick his brain doesn't
function well technically no because
they were just dating but it was her
fault that this happened that's why you
just visit then you gets all her fault
of course it's the woman's fault here
you knew how [ __ ] crazy her ex was
that's right why did you why did you let
this happen why did you move to another
[ __ ] city to get away from me who
made this man go crazy and why didn't
you tell him how crazy he was see cuz he
could have killed him first I would have
been sold off to his joking down how did
he find out where he lived and
everything that's [ __ ] crazy did she
tell you that's what I was just thinking
probably was all open about it posted on
Facebook you'd find that [ __ ] pretty
easy what if she's still friends with
them so you ain't gonna do nothing to my
new memo chop his dick off yeah wish you
would here's my address go to him that's
my new man go chop his dick off and
carve your name in his legacy I dare you
correction I said Ohio this took place
in Illinois moist right now he chopped
off too though he has the post percent
of it so it's only a hundred grand but
the idea that he could even do that and
then still be out chillin is crazy
because there's like really rich
criminals yeah exactly that's why the
bail industry is such a weird thing that
let's say you go BAM one hundred
thousand and you can get out of jail
chop another dick off you bail for
nonviolent crimes yeah shouldn't be an
option dude and then like he should get
his dick chopped off so reasonable some
people were commenting in the comments
of the article they were like man I just
put them in general population and jail
and prison and ignore the cries for help
coming from this area yeah I don't
understand
cruel and unusual
because like if you did something cruel
and unusual then it's not that cruel and
unusual for you yeah how about I'm being
well it's because of the people that are
in there that are like false it's like
if falsely accused yeah oh and it's like
I didn't [ __ ] cook what about like a
hardcore like for sure there's evident
like there's just for sure was you
especially if they're like yup I cut his
dick off and there's camera footage the
way the death penalty have you've been
convicted it's not like they go oh these
convictions are a hundred percent and
these are the like 75 percent we're not
sure but they're like dude we're gonna
put him over I got falsely accused of
sexual harassment when I was in
elementary school did the backpack touch
somebody in the butt no so I was living
in Virginia the time and I was probably
[ __ ] ten years old okay so in my
neighborhood we all knew each other
we're all friends and there was a note
that was found in the woods randomly and
in the note it said to this girl
Courtney who we all knew who was like
the neighborhood for friend girl it said
like that like hey Courtney like I want
to see you tomorrow afternoon wear
something tight and sexy Steve green or
Stephen green cuz I went by Stephen my
friend and and then the the school got
involved you didn't write it someone
else [ __ ] no I was going down though
like they were just like this is very
serious
then I kid we can't believe you do this
they were like grilling me for hours
like being like you did this [ __ ] and I
was like I didn't do it I'll [ __ ]
care I didn't do it I was be like go
look at my hand ready you're my sister
did that [ __ ] my sis no the school
didn't give a [ __ ] I was going down
right my sister went around the
neighborhood and got writing symbols
from everybody in the neighborhood and
it didn't even matter about the the
handwriting she was able to match the
[ __ ] paper to our of my friend's
sister Micah I think God does [ __ ] like
thank god she's like mildly like on the
psychopath and used her super powers
like for me for yeah
so this chick had to come and apologize
to me school never apologized to me
nothing but she admitted to it I don't
know she should be the [ __ ] her and
her friend were doing in the woods like
thought it was funny they thought it was
funny I wish you Kourtney auras corny
evolved no Kourtney was the was the girl
I was supposed to be talking about and
then her name was Adele and her and her
friend Debbie did it was so [ __ ]
shitty
say they older yeah they were older now
versus older of my friends older so just
one of them probably had a crush on you
yeah probably some stupid [ __ ] like that
one who knows but dude I was going down
and then and the school didn't give a
[ __ ] what I said oh that's what happens
all the time we'll do it exactly so I'm
always on that I'm always like do we
need evidence and proof um yes please
cuz I was like I was like saying I swear
to God and cry and be like no [ __ ]
way I did this [ __ ] and they didn't give
a [ __ ] they got the proof and then
they're just like oh well look it just
goes away so then the girls never have
any consequences against them and then
and then it's just like okay well hey
hey at least we got it weird out right
it's like dude that's why I hated
elementary school man cuz I just get
bullied all the time and then I would
tell the story about what it was it
doesn't matter everybody else no not not
everybody's at fault I hated that [ __ ]
is not at fault right so if I [ __ ] this
kid up because he trying to take my [ __ ]
and beat me up [ __ ] my did fall he
died I mean I [ __ ] a hater let me
just go because of that [ __ ] but then on
the other side I also got sexually
[ __ ] you know diddled or whatever the
[ __ ] by a gay dude when I was passed out
I talked about it here your boy yeah so
it's like damn dude I'm like [ __ ]
[Music]